ah hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play cuphead hello
hi welcome to cuphead how's it going
everybody my name is markiplier and we
are in business because we've got seven
gold coins and we've got pork rind here
that's gonna sell us some good stuff now
I still have an ad because right now I
have the immunity - but that sometimes
gets me in more trouble than it's worth
but also it's really worth trouble I
don't know if I can eat any of these
kablooie that's nice do I gotta buy
these to be able to get the super zero
the supers available somewhere else yeah
I'm gonna buy it
just in case I like the sound of
kablooey yeah I'm gonna go complete
Shore range with great damage that's
also pretty good I'm gonna do this one
charge radial barrage hole to attack Oh
precision is key so all right bye-bye
okay hi guys welcome alright so we we've
beaten all the bosses on the first
island as far as I can tell and I've got
no supers I have no idea what I'm doing
they're only had the one charm shot be
shot eh you know I'm gonna go for it not
because I believe in myself but because
I'm I'm all about figuring out what I
need to do okay so we got to make our
way over to the second island which
means that we're
and oh hi begone spirits away your real
house about to hit you with old Paree
move that's how you deal with ghosts
around here only a nitwit tries shooting
someone who ain't really there speaking
of not being places would you fellas
mind moving on is spooking the fish
aren't you a fish I guess I didn't give
you a mausoleum one that seems
oh look at my fairies Kooskia coin oh
I'm good at this uh-huh where's my super
ability oh they're so cute though
look at these goddamn pieces of food
nope nice well I want all buncha give me
a challenge here hey I got an
achievement Perry performance I don't
know what that means but I think it
means I parried a lot whoa-ho-ho
it's a dude
not today that's a lot of slacker all
right
yeah my hair is not red anymore Wow
where have you been
oh hi gosh I don't know how to thank you
boys for saving me again it's just me
unless you're talking about Cup hat and
me but even that is a little weird for
my men's didn't even introduce myself
I'm known as the legendary chalice
pleased to meet you I was searching for
magic and got trapped by these ghosts
speaking of magic boy please accept this
gift it should help there are other
mausoleums around inkwell aisle I just
wonder okay all right then did that give
me a super yorlok the new super why dear
me you mustn't forget that magical super
arts have to be equipped in the menu
before use oh oh devastating attack
spills from your head horizontal only
grounder air okay I don't know why
things are gonna be spilling from my
head but I got a super yeah that was
that was the mausoleum of Slava alright
hello you look fun the dye house a nice
wall hey you want to get shot Julia shot
you wanna get shot of shooting you well
ain't that pip looks like you really put
the kibosh on the deadest you can head
over to the next style anymore marks you
for you to lean on where
okay see that's no good I love the music
got the music in this game is so
delightful
guys hang on thank the stars I caught up
with you I believe I found a way out of
this mess you're in
hot dog you have your strength is
growing you'll soon be a match for that
no-good King dice and maybe even the
devil and surf golly do you really think
I do but you'll never get close to the
devil unless you already have those soul
contracts in hand only then will you get
a chance to turn the tables and feed so
when that time comes do the right thing
okay all right well grandpa I don't know
why you're sending me to go and kill the
devil that's uh that's a bit of a tall
order for me grandpa I don't know what
you're thinking but okay these guys are
sad why they said whoever heard of a
barbershop trio if we can't find our
fourth member will never sound right
again be a pal and let us hell if you
spot him won't you I'll do my best
can't promise nothing Bob do my best oh
good timing fellas I just had an upgrade
to your airplanes
now you can wall up your foes with bombs
you switch whenever your weapons
whatever you've tried your fancy okay
try it out
Oh your airplanes are now equipped with
mini bombs which weapons oh okay all
right then I don't know why that's a
thing but Oh baroness von bonbon
Sugarland chilly okay all right oh whoa
all right hello boy you just got ate up
no oh okay well that's a that's a
maneuver apparently okay well apparently
I'm terrible at this
and I haven't learned it yet
I don't know what I'm aiming for either
well that's okay it's okay everybody
it's okay okay everybody hold on yeah
whoa whoa whoa bastard you wanna go out
okay that's weird
your little pillows French very strange
actually I got caught right in the blast
of them yeah this oh my god this thing
is crazy yeah this good is insane
whatever get out here yourself whoa hey
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa hey
whoa whoa was that a slap opportunity
come on I missed it
sorry all right hang on I got this guy's
[Laughter]
yeah I don't like the way you've grown
before you explode that's just a little
off-putting to be perfectly honest oh
god damn it I'm such a fool
odd of course cuz I get hit by that
whatever bring out the next one Oh God
breaker oh oh no not that way oh crap
crap
damn bleep that was a slap opportunity
but I missed it slapping oh there we go
got you alright jawbreaker go wait slap
ah too low for the slag whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa how is
that fair
Oh how is that fair I didn't know you
had the shotgun
I know you had a shotgun I'm sorry about
that one all right I got this did you
ah
[Laughter]
[Music]
easy peasy he easy street Oh waffle man
that's a slap okay got that oh no oh no
[Music]
oh [ __ ] goddamnit snap okay alright
whatever comes next I got a hit hard oh
yes this guy okay well I can do mine
[Music]
wait that did nothing I fine
oh boy oh boy oh - right into it what
else was I gonna do ah god damn it okay
hang on I got this I got this I got this
guys everybody hold on to your horses
this is a morning Warren up war warm up
warm warm enough
[Laughter]
yeah this does a lot more damage but
also it's harder to get consistent shots
whereas the other one just it'll track
him no matter what I do so bull yeah if
I can get like repeated shot on someone
with this one there I mean they're gone
for what
[Music]
oh really the slap becomes against me
damn you slappa that was another slap of
coming at me Noah I'm a switchback
because like I said at least this one's
hits consistently oh whoa I don't like
that oh yeah that's the first guy so oh
geez jumps jiminy Christmas okay I don't
like the bah god damn it you slap a
bastard all right you stay over there I
guess hope no aah aah
yeah you walked into my trap card [ __ ]
like no don't all this groaning uh okay
that's less than good probably oh boy
that's your that's your uh [ __ ] ass okay
I don't know why you can take your head
off that's just weird
all right
[Music]
there we go see it's it's just the same
because it gets a number of shots in
like I don't miss like the other ones
good if there was an opportunity to
switch over and I guess switching
weapons is probably a smart thing to do
whenever it's necessary that way you
don't have to worry about hitting things
[Music]
that was a slap of that I just destroyed
oh no oh yeah you think you got me
answers no I'm gonna save my ultimate
war for later for the next round all
right come on come on you wanna get so
this how about some of this action
[Music]
okay I don't know effective did that do
anything good does that do good is that
good I don't know I wasn't too good oh
this is devastating this is also like
traumatic for me just personally seeing
someone's head was fly around and attack
me it's just like something I didn't
think that I was gonna see you today oh
I just lasted a little bit longer
yeah the homing one is just so much
better because then I can just focus on
dodging and I don't have to worry about
positioning for being shot god damn it I
could have gotten ha ha without being
hit what do I get
Abbey O'Brien new record all right cool
it's fine it's fine guys it's fine I got
this you don't think I got it but I got
[Music]
Baroness von bonbon
I got your soul apparently which is kind
of sad but oh well you just like to have
candy pyramid Carol all right here we go
I love that it's just rolling straight
into bosses that's that's actually one
of my favorite things about it is this
Lee it's just bosses oh okay wait I saw
slow wait slapper
oh god damn it I've seen you oh boy this
is going okay you know what I don't like
that it doesn't like me and I don't like
it so why do I even bother yo this is it
shouldn't be so mad he's just shooting
Rich's at me is it really that big of a
deal well ah you got a guess which one
is oh you got guess which one is
actually explodable I did it okay
[Music]
slapper
there's one of you there we go
oh come on
really oh come on really
oh wow god damn it okay it's fine flap
[Music]
well I do not like that skull thing oh
no why would you do this
slapper what son of a [ __ ]
there's no way that's possible I gotta
go through this without being it I just
gotta aim for the face that's all it is
it's this is fair all right yeah yeah
yeah the face I get it the face got
blows face I got it I got I got I got
that flapper ah got you slap oh come on
[Music]
ie ie ie ie ie ie ie ie ie ie oh come on
stupid piece of poo fine
it's got one HP left which is oh hello
hi how are you I don't trust you at all
nope don't trust that why in fact I hate
that actually actively i ah I just buys
oh come on oh yeah yay this guy's gonna
be yeah Janey
oh boy alright I got this I don't like
the bombs bombs just slap up dad's don't
like slapping oh yeah miss that slap up
it it's okay are you slapping oh no oh
no I'm in the wrong place
oh no no slapper
[Music]
you're fine everything's fine I just
gotta concentrate easy easy peasy easy
got it all right easy now I've got my
super ready boy Oh baby boom Hey
[Music]
there you go there you go there you go
there you go get out of here get out of
here you stupid genie I don't know why
I'm even finding a genie in the first
place seems like oh oh that I don't like
to look at that know what oh that that's
scary okay well weird don't know why oh
god I'm not even halfway there
I'm not even halfway there do you know
what I'm not gonna go for I'm just gonna
go for the other one oh come on why
there you go that's what mysteriously
I'm a magical day is that is the
butthole by the way you guys see the
part at the bottom and it's one of the
spinning rotating things
I guess this would be fine too
if I actually just use this a lot then
I'm just faster I guess I should use
that more it's so much less forgiving
why are there no slapos in this that's
right run away okay so it's not really
I'm beating phases of them we just got a
lot of phases that he switches between a
lot get Bob I'm assuming this does more
damage
[Music]
oh I can't I can't slap a wallet oh god
I i can't slap a ball I'm dodging but I
got this I got this I got this I got
this I got this I got this I got this I
got this
[Music]
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
the easiest thing in the world the
easiest thing in the world you know why
it's about skilled I'm easy to sing in
the world whoa whoa whoa easiest thing
in the world the easiest thing in the
world the easiest thing in the world wha
Boesky don't miss me oh come on what
happened to my invisible nodes dang
daggit
dang damn it damn it damn it damn it
better with this anyway
[Music]
yeah read my thoughts read my thoughts
yeah oh yeah I care I care a lot about
that
[Music]
rapper APIs here we go
oh no the slap of God me god damn it
that's right get out of here get out of
here get out of here whoa I don't like
that I don't like that I don't like that
I don't like that I don't like that I
don't like that at all
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy
oh oh you i bastard
oh you am bastard oh you I bastard okay
now go this
[Music]
yes
I need a better button to switch weapons
I need to change my switch weapon button
cuz it's just too hard cuz I have to
stop shooting right now okay switch
weapon he needs to be is anything B
right now that'll be B okay
replace with B all right got it cool so
now I can switch yeah that's way better
that's way better it's gonna take a
little bit of learning curve on that one
now but you know it's okay it's okay
it's gonna be better overall better for
everybody because there's a strategy to
switching weapons on the fly and if you
learn how to do that you're gonna
maximize your damage output and if you
do learn to do that then you're gonna
win since me come mark Flyers rules of
fighting this is better
[Music]
like I got guy got blown right out of
the gate I'm gonna save this this alt
for the next one oh god this I got this
guy's everyone calm down try try try try
try try try try try try try try just try
okay ah God
slap that was my bad that's my bad does
my dad know not oh why oh god I forgot
the brick I'm such an idiot
oh no oh no oh no oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh boy I've really really used myself
I've really really goofed myself Oh
[Music]
Oh god damn it damn it damn it damn it
damn it damn it damn it damn it damn it
damn it
Oh nope okay alright not gonna get hit
that early not gonna get hit that or not
gonna get hit that early whoa that's new
okay I haven't seen that Oh cats okay ah
no no really no okay cats that's weird I
don't know where you can't find I can't
hit you oh I can't hit you okay that's
well that at least is a solid answer
[Music]
okay
ah new clothes go close too close for my
comfort
way too close
easy piece easy peasy
[Music]
what
easy as usual easy confusions easiest
thing in the world the easiest thing in
the world the easiest thing in the world
these are you sing in the world leaves
you singing the woman it's so easy so
easy so easy so sleazy so easy Weezy
[Music]
yo yeah here we go
you ball baby but no oh my god let's go
slap slap ah it's okay this I didn't get
hit
no not oh jeez I keep forgetting I've
already forgotten slap nope there we go
there we go okay come on you see Daisy
oh wow how are you supposed to be able
to avoid that how in the world let's go
hey baby
hey again I got hit right right before
the end I almost did a flawless game but
hey I got you baby I got you baby with
the slapper again almost almost got
almost got named Plus almost got if I
didn't get hit right at the end there
would have been totally fine okay dizzy
me GV do you see me hi yah yah yah yah
yah yah yah yah yah yah yah I've done
all right carnival kerfuffle all right I
got this ah with the power the slap I
ain't gonna get into all right I don't
like you I don't wait wait wait wait I
should have known that was gonna happen
hang on no try again come on Oh got ya
ring around the Rosie come on come on
come on come on come on oh yeah hey miss
me
what oh come on I slept with that I'm
very obviously slip odd that NASA
playing a game of chicken I don't like
it oh oh that ain't good for that that's
not good I like this guy ah that's it ah
come on my stupid slappa I gotta I gotta
bolt
oh I wasn't watching for the dark with
the bomb but
[Music]
there you go there you go all right I'm
gonna try this close range gonna hit him
real hard come on
Oh what that doesn't hit in the corner
mm-hmm I don't believe that I don't
believe that I don't believe that for a
second yeah you'll float - yeah we'll
all flow
[Music]
why isn't this doing as much damage all
come on really
no God [ __ ] a duck alright I'm gonna
keep going anyway even though I'm
definitely gonna die oh why I don't
understand why I'm freezing up there
alright it's fine I was gonna die let me
try the other weapon does you see Oh a
little too early on that literally
[Music]
[ __ ]
ah
[Music]
correct [ __ ]
oh come on I slapped with that
[Music]
okay okay okay okay yeah when I can just
focus on dodging I'm really not why I
did not expect you to shoot horseshoes
out there
all right that's weird that was super
weird I don't know what that was all
about no my super I activated my super
before that before I got tablet by the
slap come on I got it I got it everybody
hang on I got this you think I don't got
this
you don't know me close there buddy
we're not that friendly we're not that
friendly a hole not that friendly
dickwad weird that friendly ass blaster
went that friendly boo sacker Greg that
friendly corn shucker wait that friendly
Billy
[Music]
oh come on I feel so stupid I hate I
just ain't being stupid you know the
first thing can't believe I hate is it
worth feeling big dumb living my life in
as dumb as I am
[Music]
ah I thought I slapped with that but I
don't need to
oh come on it was going up my high who's
God you really pull guarded by high man
ah you're dead now so is your horse fine
oh well that's sad I'm not really sad
about it but sad I guess Oh
well that don't look good oh boy what is
this what is this nightmare whoa I can't
see [ __ ] there's so much happening oh
that ain't good okay don't like it nope
ah this is the worst thing I've ever
seen oh boy
Oh what I landed on it no oh come on
come on come on I was right there are
you kidding me
I missed my last jump
I missed my last jump and that's the
punishment I get god damn you to hell
and back
I hope the devil takes your soul and
does something sinister with it you
piece of boo you gosh no I'm a slap of
you in the next century mister miss I
don't know god damn it god damn it damn
it I will sight read that last piece of
[ __ ]
[Music]
yes switching weapons is helpful very
helpful ah got you [ __ ] you're gonna do
now
your stupid horses ain't gonna do Oh got
it kid ah stupid jump [ __ ] hate you
I hate you get the next one I'm gonna
get the next one
that's right didn't even need to do that
didn't even need to didn't have a near
to do that why needs baby on a piece of
garbage
this time I'm not gonna miss my jump
even though it's really difficult
there's so many moving things isn't big
like I can't I lose track of where I am
so easily no no I got damnit oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy I'm not I'm
gonna miss I'm gonna miss again whoa
whoa
Oh you could slap on the train oh I
didn't know that wait what you could
slap the train what no way
wait I got to go back into that can i
play that again
wait what you could slap with a train no
way that be the clown wait hang on wait
I got slapped with the train I've got a
slap of that train yeah I promise this
won't take long
won't take long I just got to get to the
train part and slap at the train because
if you can man epochs that makes it so
much easier
[Music]
well that was my bad but I don't want to
finish this so it's fine okay so the
nose of the train okay the nose of the
train okay I'm ready I'm ready I'm
waiting oh oh well that didn't do
anything okay all right well I thought
that was gonna like changing things
oh I thought it was okay that's fine you
know it's fine I thought that was gonna
be like the train would suddenly get
shot off the rails and into nowhere town
ah okay all right let's back it down
like that okay yeah I'm just gonna walk
away from now and pretend I didn't see
that might drink away the memory of
whatever the hell that was
cuz holy crap yep not not still
nightmare floating like decapitated
ahead of some old guy ah boy that's
that's a nightmare that won't go away
poor boy hey nope nope still horrible
still horrible everything about that
horrible okay how's it going ah for all
your battles and all my rhymes you have
failed in Paris 45 times you know what
[ __ ] you dad I didn't need that dick
all right fine whatever piece of [ __ ]
well that was a seven does is a
disappointment through and through and
this is Al and good al and get some coin
edge here frazzle frazzle frat-house
frazzle okay all right oh whoa whoa oh
oh I get it I get it
oh I do not like this at all nope that's
what I needed to do well alright well
ain't this just doors
[Music]
ah okay all right I got you I got you
hang on let's just try to just try to
get my head around the situation so oh
that's weird
okay I'm in a way no ha ha wait
well alright well then okay
[Music]
good read your eyeball right your round
your friggin eyeball what the hell
happened and your frickin eyeball out
ouchy ouchy oh well all right thing
sorry Hank I got distracted me me me me
flip me boy I know that's a slap a duck
but I can't do nothing about that slap a
duck right now
bear with me everybody oh oh god that's
horrible I don't wanna walk through that
dead fingernails hey I've seen you in in
many games ah I'm such an idiot
it's such an idiot
so the squeaking noise is horrible hey
hi hi hi guya nope
why I don't like that
okay you know what I'm just gonna go for
it okay all right Oh No
ah I my brain didn't work my brains
didn't work god damn this one is just
this one just messes with you I ain't
about this no I wanted to sapa the
others anger inside of a tic
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh what the heck what we're gonna play a
note this is such [ __ ] I hate it I
hate it this is not as bad as not as bad
as getting over it see the thing about
the between this and getting over it's
getting over it as hard and unfair this
is hard but at least it's fair you know
at least when I die I'm like ah how's my
fault but in the other one that I won't
mention by name here the game that shall
not be named that does not feel like my
fault it never feels like my fault
that's the thing it's never me feeling
like I'm inadequate as a player it's
never that and that may just be my own
ego trying to save myself but alas Oh
today
[Music]
stupid tuba he's gonna blow me Oh No
walk right into your bra take some of
this that not that it was necessary so
scary
tonight you again you piece of poop but
[Music]
what if that's why I would you do that
don't do that whoa rap
wait what we've detected copyrighted
audio and video in your stream your
stream may be temporarily blocked and
what excuse me was that temporary wait a
minute YouTube okay you've detected
quote-unquote this is literally a
message I just got from YouTube heads-up
we detected copyrighted audio and video
in your stream oh really oh and what
would that be from from cuphead oh okay
great that's wonderful thank you for
being so lovely in everything that you
do I'm so glad I'm so glad you're here
for me YouTube when I need you the most
you are always just a wonderful soul and
I sure do love streaming on YouTube
which I don't and I'm not gonna well hey
there fellas come to watch my little
show have you know I haven't they say
juggling is a bit like burying tough at
first but soon you can string them
together swimmingly
I'm oven to get for some day four in a
row yeah that would be something
wouldn't it okay alright alright
whatever
fiery frolic alright let's do this one
yeah it's whatever it's oh hello you
[Music]
that was wonderful yeah who knows who
knows what YouTube's all about I mean to
be perfectly honest I I know so little
like of what's going on but it's like
there's so many there's so many I don't
know you know it's just like what can I
even say about it at this point that
hasn't already been said that everyone's
already talking about it it's just it is
what it is and we all have to live with
it we're slave to it but uh why I didn't
know your tale was coming up out of
nowhere it's really nothing to be done
about the diapers like it's not
something I never tried to complain
about YouTube especially in front of you
guys because that's the least thing that
you guys need to worry about cuz YouTube
like being a dick to me is once again
it's my problem
it's not you guys you guys are here just
to watch me fail at cuphead and that's
it just have a laugh and that's all I
really want you guys to worry about
because everything else is like it's
ancillary it's what I have to deal with
in that's not what your worries are all
about and the last thing that you guys
need is me to add on to the stress of
your already stressful lives you come
here because you want to get away and
you want to have a break and that that's
the only thing that I I love about you
guys being here with me and that's like
that's why the last thing that I want to
do is bog you down with my problems
yeah cuz in the end it's like this it's
just like YouTube will be as YouTube is
like no matter what I'll still want to
create videos and I'll still want to do
what I want to do but YouTube being a
dick like that again that's just a
company that is is creating a platform
that I am borrowing I don't own this
platform in any way even if the content
creators are the main fuel of why this
platform exists I'm just a small part of
it and even if I get like stopped from
what I'm do
then you know like there's still gonna
be other ways that I can create videos
and and make you know make people happy
and and give people a break from their
their lives so when it comes down to
like the stress of YouTube and what
people talk about like in terms of
monetization it's a problem it is
affecting people's livelihoods but at
the same time that's not your problem
like that's not something you need to
worry about I will take care of an i but
I have more than enough resources to be
able to handle it for what it is and I
have more of them enough things at my
disposal right now to be able to create
what I want to create and that's that's
lovely yeah and this love is what I'm
able to do with what I have it and even
if even if like things you know did
somehow remove all ads from all my
videos and I suddenly wasn't making
money anymore you know I still would be
able to like fuel what I do in a lesser
respect but I'd still be able to feel
with what I do because like I do this
because I absolutely love doing this
it's not as much as it as a like oh yeah
sure mark it's not about the money but
really like it never has been about the
money for me because for example like I
never really talked about it but who
killed markiplier like that was a that
was a money negative project even with
the shirts we sold as merch for who
killed markiplier like that still lost
money because one of the things like we
ran that whole thing on a budget like we
made the whole thing like on a
shoestring budget and even then you want
to know what the the grand total of how
much that actually cost was like that
cost
not including not including the salaries
that I normally pay for like everyone on
the team which I do pay and I pay them
very well not counting them not coming
just counting like the equipment the
location the actors that were a part of
it the other the other resources not
counting the time an hourly thing that
costs a hundred and fifteen thousand
dollars was how much
cost to make and that was with us
editing it us shooting it us doing
everything about it when it came down to
props rentals like location and then the
other wonderful actors that were a part
of it who I want to pay fairly and I do
I want to play them absolutely fairly in
it that's one of my biggest things I
always want to make sure that whenever I
I hire someone I pay them fairly it
costs $115,000 and that's again that's
not including like the hourly cost of
editing that that I pay like Ethan and
Catherine and and Amy and Tyler you know
and myself I guess technically I have to
pay to I guess but no I didn't make any
money off of that and I lost somewhere
in them somewhere in the rains have
probably what cost me after the shirts
and what little ad revenue there was
from it like probably lost about fifty
thousand or something like that just to
just to make that happen but that's the
thing that like what why I talk about
those numbers it's not to brag about
like God's cost so much money is like
it's it's to say like really to make
great stuff the money doesn't matter to
me I don't care if that loses money
because it was so worth making like the
same with a date with markiplier like a
date with markiplier was a lot cheaper
in terms of raw resources but we did
have to buy a lot of equipment initially
and we even though he's a shoestring we
still had to pay the actors in it and
it's like that still costs like prior
losses maybe 15,000 20
because we didn't sell shirts for that
but it was a lot cheaper but when it
comes to those projects and the things
that are really cool and and really
matter like that's that's the things
that I don't I don't really care because
I've been super fortunate to be where I
am in terms of YouTube and in terms of
like just beat up God was one of you and
in terms of just welp Wow okay don't
shoot those things apparently alright
but when it comes to just in terms of
making that sort of stuff like it
doesn't matter to me it really doesn't
matter to me because in the long run
those are gonna be the things that
people remember out of what I do you
know no one's gonna remember like
cuphead part 23 no one's gonna remember
like subnautica part 47 you know it
really comes and not saying those videos
are any less important than like the who
killed markiplier of the world but it
when it comes down to the special things
like the things that will be remembered
because someone said hey the money is
less important than the quality and
that's gonna be like the who killed mark
Lara for the world you know that's gonna
be like that's gonna be like the date
with Martha bugs it's gonna be like the
markiplier TV which like those things
people never consider like the the pure
monetary costs in it is a damn shame
that YouTube does like have these
policies enabled been like inhibit a lot
of creative energy in
the things that we do but at the same
time he always got to remember that hey
this is temporary and this is really
cool that what we're able to do here
whoa God that would be a good time had
to do this and you know it may be
temporary and maybe it'll all die out
and maybe it won't
maybe we'll be fine maybe maybe things
to go along maybe ads will get better
maybe they'll be like a subscription
service that built into YouTube I mean
YouTube red Khan is that way but we
really don't see a lot of that YouTube
red money but yeah when it come cut damn
it I'm just doing fine up until this
point yeah but when it comes down to
stuff like that I don't worry about the
money
I really don't and I don't want you guys
to worry about the money I want you guys
to worry about what cool projects is
coming out next how we're gonna surprise
you like what what what next thing I'm
gonna do to push myself that's the only
thing I want you guys to worry about
this what's gonna come next what kind of
cool things happen and oh this is a bad
idea to use that that that tracking gun
because that tracking gun is gonna give
me a killer okay I got it
yeah anyway so that's all anyway I'll
stop ranting about that there's no real
point well no there's no real point
about branding about it because the
world is in a bad enough place like
we've got to fight net neutrality and or
not [ __ ] that we gotta fight net
neutrality we gotta fight against the
people that are trying to repeal on that
neutrality we've got to fight against
like people's rights to live in love you
know the last thing you guys need to
worry about is Oh ad revenue is down
this month
everybody get your pitchfork right now
Oh YouTube rewind wasn't good this year
everybody you know those are not the
things you guys need to worry about what
you need to worry about is what cool
project you guys can watch
you guys like you guys should have the
freedom to watch whatever you want to
watch in whatever way you want to watch
and like just provide a little escape
from the troubles of today that's what
my that's why I don't talk about like a
lot of political stuff I don't talk
about a lot of stuff like that I just
want to focus on the good and I want to
focus on what's what's making people
laugh and I want to focus on what's
making people excited about the future
Oh what what makes people excited about
like what people are making and even
inspiring people to make more stuff
because I never want to discourage
anybody from becoming a youtuber just
because I'm like oh it's I saw an ad
revenue well I'm just an idiot ad
revenue is down you know I always wanted
to just like make stuff that inspires
people to make more stuff that's all
I've everyone well god damn it why am I
not paying attention to that god damn it
I lost three hit points in the easiest
part of this entire freaking glass god
it's so stupid anyway whatever what was
I saying about yeah whatever it is what
it is you know as I always say it is
what it is bastard with the slapper
[Music]
I'm okay nope that frickin wobble wobble
wobble I will get another slap I promise
I will
[Music]
come on come on come on I don't want to
waste it here oh oh oh
[Music]
Paul that was the clutches - I've ever
had I don't want to waste here I want to
use it on the next one because I want to
get through this next one quick
[Music]
and last II Oh
oh come on why doesn't it make me
invulnerable for like a second after I
do that well it's just gonna discourage
me from doing supers no oh didn't see
the second one [ __ ] this they're very
hard to see focus on them
[Music]
okay
okay God okay I got to hit points going
in this next one now I gotta switch guns
I don't want to be stupid oh no this is
gonna be just as bad oh oh oh no oh it's
just as bad just as bad okay there's no
good way to go about that one okay
alright that's this gonna be a tough one
this is gonna be a tall but I got this
[Music]
slappa slappa
I almost like this better than the other
ones at least that like has consistency
to it I know I'm so stupid God God
subscribe ailment Diana free try that
one hey I don't even know what the the
intermediate super of this one is
actually I guess that's a funny that's a
funny observation whoa oh okay well I
could fall off that's also an option for
me to do well jump right into and then
I'm gonna die but I think I've got I
think I've got a better way about this
at least cut damn it I'm trying to slap
it
[Music]
sorry I'm concentrating so I got to be a
better woman whoa whoa whoa what's got
my super ready go down already jeez I've
been whaling on you for like 15 minutes
now oh really oh really oh really why no
what does this does not do as much
damage that's just what this does okay
[ __ ] stain all right you know what I
just don't like you okay let's hope that
yep I land right on it after my super
that's wonderful that's wonderful that's
wonderful the way that is I hate that
I'm fine it's fine fine
[Music]
screen slapping damn slapper
yeah almost got a super already what are
you gonna do about it huh
[Music]
are you
yep that's how I roll baby
oh no what's this oh I've got the magic
touch baby I've got the magic Midas
touch oh no no come on I that was my
fault entirely is literally then it was
entirely my fault and I'm a dumbest
[Music]
and these keep these guys just keep
getting higher and higher hello
whoa I was I look away for one second
and that's what happens
hey it's higher and higher health pools
it's a six this is like the longest time
now to beat a boss I'm gonna guess
that's the point that's really the only
way it's gonna get harder yeah you're
scary not like the way you look oh no
don't chase after him that's not oh my
god oh that's so ah man oh wow that is
rough I can do this though I know I can
do this it's just like it keeps tracking
them at once they get close I may have
the ride may have to go switch weapons
out but it's alright it's alright
[Music]
no no no no no no no no no Jesus oh well
really okay you know what I hate you
this and you made me waste that that and
then I'm dead okay all right well [ __ ]
[Music]
shut shut all right I'm gonna change I'm
gonna change I'm gonna change weapons
real quick and then I'm gonna go yeah I
got I got a yeah I got the short one is
not what I what it was cracked up to be
I actually really don't like the short
one so I'm just gonna stick with this
one and I think this is gonna be better
yeah there's gonna be better because a
straight shot forward is really all I
really need yeah that's a good stuff
that's what we in the business call the
good stuff oh yeah it charges up the
super way faster if you get hit with
this thing by the way
[Music]
I don't even think like do you really
need any other weapons I mean yeah the
the the homing one helps with getting
things getting maximizing the number
hits but yeah see what he just went
farther into his other place way
bastards so now if I switch through this
one which will be handy
they don't always need to aim
[Music]
and I'ma save my super for the next one
if I can get if I can stay on a cloud
[Music]
no no no no no I knew that was gonna
have a god dammit I'm such an idiot
whoa-oh look away you second poop hey
there we go
why don't why aren't you why aren't you
invincible like just for the second a
feeder and why do I keep losing life on
that one like of all the ones to lose
life on of all the the moments in this
game to lose anything why in the parade
thing
[Music]
don't lie me I just know whoa whoa oh
good
[Music]
sorry I'm a frustrated puppy
no again I'm such an idiot I know it's
happening I'm getting frazzled when I
get frazzled like it's stupid
[Music]
all right
Oh No
your pit I got this I got this getting
toasty I'm getting toasted guys I'm
gonna toast the cup Cup the toast get a
cup of joe
not a cup of Choate but a cup of joe
[Music]
easiest thing in the world the easiest
thing in the world the easiest thing in
the world the easiest thing in the world
this is so easy so easy
[Music]
so easy easy singing the worthy the
easiest thing in the world the easiest
thing in the world
[Music]
I almost ran into that guy who almost
ran into that guy cuz I wasn't paying
attention
stay away I gotta stay away as far as I
can knocking nope oh okay that's fun
you're fun how about this for photo I'm
gonna fall I'm gonna fall no no oh maybe
not
yes and you're fun you're fun you're fun
you're fun you're fun ah you are super
fun I don't know what that is
oh god damn it you're not fun at all I
changed my mind you're not funny you're
the opposite of fun
[Music]
oh god damn it again same nope no aah
god damn it no god damn it it's fine I
literally I know I was like a don't go
in the middle
but then what did i do i go in the
freakin middle is an idiot oh I got this
I got this
[Music]
you don't need a special weapon to be
able to do this I'm gonna get through
this with all skill and you guys are
gonna see it happening in front of your
eyes in front of his eyes
[Music]
there we go yeah run away run away
little [ __ ] baby run away run away
that's right
[Music]
ah nope oh boy okay yes they are the
model
[Music]
give me another super give me another oh
[ __ ]
wasn't I looked away got one second
that's all it really takes
[Music]
Oh Rick I wasn't even thinking okay
another super is up but I'm gonna wait
I'm gonna wait patiently cuz I'm patient
like a butterfly and finish him finish
him finish him I need him no why
how is this not finished
hey good God who's two seconds two
seconds away
okay all right ah lobbers for pansies
who can't beat it right if you're
telling me to use lobber that means
you're not skilled enough to beat them
with the regular shot like I did so high
in your face I'm better than you
so thank you everybody so much for
watching I'm sorry those was really rude
of me of how to rub in your face how
much better I am than you that was
really rude of me I apologize for that
of how how big our skill difference is I
apologize for that gap so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you think down the comments
below I don't know if I'm gonna do
another livestream of it so stay tuned
check out mark Blair comm for new
sweatshirts that I got and tour tickets
we're going back on tour in January and
February in Europe so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye bye bye guys bye bye